meine lieben mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger innen
eigentlich war ich fest davon überzeugt
dass im januar vorbei ist aber 2021
denkt genauso an wie 2020 aufgehört hat
im fasten ist auch wahr
wenigstens kommt jetzt der impfstoff
jetzt sparen gehe ich kriege nicht die
erste spritze ich bin risikogruppe man
singt es mir nicht an aber ich bin über
50 und abo und blutdruck man war das ein
scheiß ja wobei endlich hatte man mal
wieder zeit für seine lieben so viel
zeit mit der familie und wir schätzen
endlich die systemrelevanten berufe
pflegepersonal kassiererinnen was haben
die sich im frühling gefolgt über den
applaus vom balkon
lasst uns die weiteren nicht mit geld
klar dass kriegen andere milliarden für
lufthansa und tui aber luftreiniger für
schulklassen gibt es nicht zu teuer
da reicht fenster auf auch im januar
einziger trost liebe kinder ihr könnt
euren europa jetzt antworten
doch opa ich weiß wie das in stalingrad
war kalt corona können wir noch nicht zu
den akten legen aber donald trump ende
januar wird präsident biden vereidigt
und dann will ich über den grün orangen
man nie wieder eine sekunde nachdenken
das wird so schön leider bleibt uns ein
neues wort erhalten querdenken
gibt es eigentlich gar nicht es gibt nur
denken und das geht nach vorne und quer
denken halt quer für die ist christian
dorsten ein gefährlicher spieler und der
wendler ein seriöser wissenschaftler
mehr muss man nicht wissen guter vorsatz
für das neue jahr mit dem rauchen und
mit dem querdenken aufhören beides
beschissene angewohnheiten postet das
aller aufträge und bitte nicht
verwechseln mit querdenken das ist was
ganz anderes
2021 wird das erste jahr ohne
großbritannien in der eu
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich es aushalten
soll ohne die großartigen englischen
produkte wie im büro oder auch übrigens
2021 ist natürlich das letzte jahr unter
kanzlerin merkel im herz des bundestags
war der einzige kanzlerkandidat der
schon feststeht ist olaf scholz
[Gelächter]
das meinen die wirklich ernst beck
baerbock laschet machen wir uns nichts
vor die nächste ansprache halte ich
unter kanzler
ja sorry ich kann es nicht ändern
2021 ist jedenfalls eine menge los was
da alles nachgeholt wird die fußball-em
olympia der neue james bond man immer
nur zweimal hochzeit musicals helene
fischer und marc forster konzerte dafür
verzichte ich jetzt gerne nochmal auf
den urlaub das wird super ich vertreibe
jetzt die bösen kroner geister vom
letzten jahr pilgern ist dieses jahr
auch nicht okay den spar ich mir fürs
nächste jahr auf alles drauf frohes 2021
hallo leute ich bin's der heute show we
may hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt
mit - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller
[Musik]